hoch feiert das publikum kennen sie die
gasse
diese dynastie von traum verkäufern wie
keine andere familie bestimmen sie die
schweizer zirkuswelt
höhenflüge und abstürze break ihre
geschichte lernen sie sie kennen die
welt der sensationen willkommen im
zirkus der familie gasser
[Musik]
als der kidsclub stärker gesetzlich
hallo letzte chance
großes kino mit großen tieren
das ist die welt von madagaskar im
freizeitpark connyland
das connyland ist der bekannteste
gastbetrieb und der kern der dynastie
[Applaus]
wie so oft in der geschichte der gasser
unternehmen steht das kontinent an einem
wendepunkt
weil in der schweiz keine delfine mehr
importiert werden dürfen verliert der
freizeitpark sein markenzeichen
seit sie ein kind ist arbeitet nahtlos
mit delfinen ihr vater conny gasser
brachte die shows in die schweiz doch
seit immer wieder tiere gestorben sind
ist die haltung von delfinen in
gefangenschaft zu umstritten
geht es ihnen schlecht
wenn nadia gasse ihre lieblinge nach der
schau streicheln können sie nicht genug
davon bekommen
schon hat die us-mutter warte ich die
trainerin
mit einer top boxen mit denen sie und
ihre
kleine tochter
hat
paris münchen
tja das ist nicht sein denn
das amt
direkt hinter dem delfin becken stehen
die villen von madagaskar und her und
router robbie denn den finnen zu nahe
wie möglich
die geschwister haben sich bisher zur
zukunft des kontinents nie geäußert sie
seien des themas überdrüssig sagten sie
mir aber schließlich wie legten sie ein
roby gasser der sohn des kontinent
gründers war berühmt für seine seelöwen
dressuren auf seinen internationalen
tourneen wurde er mit renommierten
preisen ausgezeichnet
einer der sein leben mit tieren
verbrachte soll jetzt ein tierquäler
sein roby gasser mag nicht mehr streiten
was sich laut vorschlag zähler und war
natürlich erzählt wird was schlecht
läuft die schlagzeile besser als mit der
tierschützer kamen die täter machen mit
einer schweizer roger keller man kann
nicht mit den ländern deutschland und
etwa
kämpft man muss man jetzt jahrelang bad
oder mad auf die rede durfte ich muss
die delfine werden wohl in einen
ausländischen park gegeben die gaz
bezweifeln ob es ihnen dort besser gehen
wird denn das connyland wurde mehrfach
als bestes delfinarium europas
ausgezeichnet
kann das connyland ohne ist ein
markenzeichen noch existieren roby
gasser hat sich diese frage schon lange
gestellt und während sie noch aufgeregt
diskutiert wird hat er schon lange einen
plan b ich bin im kopf schon länger so
geplant dass ich grüße andere sachen
machen die zukunft um
fördermittel sind wie derzeit dann
irgendwo wir mehr können für größere
unternehmen wird für größere die hand so
viel land zur verfügung gestellt hat für
euch seht ihr dass sie eine burka aber
es stopp da ist von größter wert
und so werden im connyland wo schon bald
noch mehr viel die bahn entstehen
aus nadja und robbie kinder waren hatte
auf dem areal des kontinents noch ein
anderer familienbetrieb seine heimat der
zirkus royer
peter gasser ist der cousin von rhodia
im royal verbrachten sie zusammen ihre
jugend damals betrieben ihre väter den
zirkus heute gehört der peter gasser
seit kindesbeinen stand er in der manege
als klaren seiltänzer und schon höher
sein salonwagen versprüht den charme der
alten zirkus tage all mode strömung zum
trotz kämpft peter für die zukunft des
klassischen zirkus so wie es seine
familie seit generationen tut
genau wie viel und das kriegst du sich
frank er spielt oder nicht und dann ist
das einfach wichtig dass leute das mögen
und dass das ist also sehr gut abschloss
fast in jedem schweizer zirkus sind
verwandte da grasser dynastie zu hause
john connelly starlight im stehen oder
noch im circus royal waren es neben
peter gasser noch drei brüder auf dauer
konnte das nicht gut gehen schließlich
zog einer nach dem anderen davon dann
machte peter sein lebensplan oliver
skreinig zum direktor und mitbesitzer
[Musik]
jetzt steht einer von peters brüdern vor
der tür
daniel gasser versuchte seinen eigenen
weg zu gehen war kraft mensch und
zirkusdirektor
anstrengend war dass er ist froh wieder
zu hause zu sein
perforce kita es fällt einem zu wieder
da und
krampf
möglichkeit sondern
glücksgriff denn ich bin 23
ich bin dort reicht das
qi
[Musik]
jetzt arbeitet die gasse aus
lastwagenfahrer für sein bruder
seine muskeln oma hat ihm die schultern
und knien ruiniert er ist nicht
unglücklich dass er keinen eigenen
zirkus mehr hat
und so liegt das kriegt halt verlieren
können
ihr geld verdienen werden da wo bleibt
für dani ist das leben ein täglicher
kampf gegen große und kleine
widrigkeiten
das ist größte hilft
mit zigaretten
dass ich sage ich
weiß es und chöre zu denen man schon mit
download schwachsinns und
stinkt brauchen stinkt's kreide stinken
und
gleich blöd dass die menschen sie
jetzt
sag mir das ja der roten vor du glaubst
doch
sowohl und herzinfarkt
in brühl beruf haben
noch immer ist da nie mit seinem
wohnwagen aus alten zeiten unterwegs das
gerät könnte es in woche
unterwegs mit gebrochenen träumen es ist
die die deponie
eine frau und kind
betriebe rung stoß adrenalin und ich
lasse mich ist auch ob er sich wohl
beduftung es hat es hat nicht sollen
sein
und dann hatten sie gestellt doch viel
mehr nicht weniger aus drei
verschiedenen zirkusunternehmen hat er
es versucht am ende gingen sie massiv
das kostete ihn 19 jahre und einen
herzinfarkt
ich bin
gekommen seit 32 jahren
noch nie gewagt mit corinna betätigt die
luft nehmen
und durch das weshalb man sich irgendwer
rastet der rostet und dass ich das merke
ich und das ist jetzt gut dass ich doch
andrea dober hoffe dass bald wieder
andere gedanke und ich bewege mich wie
der beetle ihm das blut im körper
sichere sondern
[Applaus]
er ist der einzige zirkus der noch eine
raubtiernummer zeigt
peters engagierte die deutsche
dompteurin carmen zander mit ihren fünf
bengalischen tigern
[Musik]
großes kino mit großen tieren
geht auch hier eine ära zu ende
kommt nach dem delfin verbot das ende
der raubtiernummer
die frau ist gut mit essig sensor
und das hier das ist wiederum dass es
gut läuft und das ist die begründung
wird sicher kurz zu sagen wir machen
aber doch passiert ist viel schuldig
solange ich solange es laut mappus und
merkel haben pinguine da wird so glaube
ich das theater
tierschützer betrieb ist
ich war eigentlich
wie mache ich haben ja 50 jähriges
jubiläum und machen die wassershow und
dann werde man ganze pinguinkolonie
engagieren
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ein jahr jünger aus peter gasser ist
sein bruder fridtjof frithjof verließ
den royal als letzter und gründer der
clans und kalorien eine varieté show mit
opulenter kulinarischer begleitung
familie und artisten helfen mit in allen
bereichen um showprogramm bis zur küche
fridtjof organisiert telefoniert und
zieht die fäden
und das ganz ohne gott sei dank
eigentlich ist auch seine heimat der
klassische zirkus wie damals im royal
als die brüder zusammen in der manege
stunden
will ich
hin
dass auch reporter und der zirkus hat
melitta das wird buchenhof einem buch
vier söhnen hat können deutlich wieder
hoch über irgendwas
mit medien oder
bei friedhofs kindern ist das interesse
am zirkus gemischt
der älteste sohn ist eingestiegen beim
mittleren hält sich die begeisterung in
grenzen
in zwei tagen ist premiere der vater ist
angespannt
berlin hat ganz andere sorgen
was vielleicht mehr geschick sich
besonders
was das er dass ich rauche und
schaut geradeaus rezenter sich gerät zu
suchen
sie haben ihren
ideen für die zukunft hätte da nicht
schon
quasi in einem inserat von deinen so im
jura weit abgelegen vielleicht ein ort
um sesshaft zu werden so
könne man häufiger trinken
hier leben seine frau und seine kinder
während er versucht aus lastwagenfahrer
etwas dazu zu verdienen
es ist eine art connyland im miniformat
doch dani land ist zu teuer und bringt
zu wenig ein
und schafft gleich weg von der autobahn
und musste hinter sich
hey große haye groß
ach ja ich weiß du hast ja
im selbstbedienungsrestaurant steht dann
ist frau am herd früher eine gefeiert
die seiltänzerin
auch ihre töchter sind artistinnen und
treten draußen im park auf einer kleinen
bühne auf
da nie versucht jetzt so bald wie
möglich aus dem pachtvertrag
auszusteigen
aber
für mich auch wenn es hier laufen würde
es war nicht mein leben
als dani und raus jung waren und voller
träume waren sie artisten wie aus dem
bilderbuch
eingefädelt hatte die beziehung der
nissan coco nie nach einem besuch bei
einem befreundeten zirkus sagte er er
habe für ihn etwas zum heiraten gesehen
es war ein bisschen überstürzt wir haben
damals schon hat keiner an uns geglaubt
ja nicht so dass sie beruf das etikett
mit masken
aber sie sollen es auch geschrieben
[Gelächter]
sie haben sich sehr gefreut das ist der
mann meiner träume das ist ein klagen
bis vor einem jahr präsentierte die
kasse jeweils am jahresende noch seinen
weihnachtscircus in st gallen
eigentlich wäre das auch dieses jahr
geplant gewesen doch wahrscheinlich
macht er jetzt erst mal eine pause
und so sitzt er abends während der
vorstellungen im zirkusrund manchmal
kommt auch die familie das geht ja auch
ohne den bruder zu fragen denn immerhin
ist ein großer
dies noch im ohr läuft gut und während
unter der kuppel der direktor das finale
präsentiert trifft peter vorbereitungen
für das abendessen
erinnerungen und seine zeit als
messerwerfer
heute bleibt der lieber im hintergrund
verschafft mir nicht was ich sage so
dass das immer so lange unterwegs sind
dass ich einfach nicht genießen das ist
für mich nicht das es immer stand sorgen
und volvo das ist eigentlich auch es ist
einzig misslangen morgen geschafft und
kommt zu haben ich bin immer der bienen
oder und unglücklich das eigentlich gar
nicht das alles als arbeiter
die spaghetti
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bei clans und kalorien macht sich
friedhof für seine premiere bereit sein
schlafzimmer wagen seien die immer
spektakel ja vielleicht sein leben sind
inszenierungen leicht verblichenen
träume kleine fluchten im harten alltag
des zirkus geschäfts
[Musik]
kino.to abgezogen
zeit seines lebens war fridtjof clown
und noch immer tritt er mit seinem tor
nummer auf
doch vielleicht ist es die kulinarische
inszenierung die fridtjof gassers
variété erfolgreich macht
es ist das rezept dieser familie wer
sich neu erfindet bleibt im geschäft
[Musik]
fehlt frau marion war früher eine
private so nennt man frauen die nicht
dass eine zirkusfamilie stammen marion
die starke frau hinter fridtjof ist
unermüdlich am baum ohne die private
liefe nichts das ist die ironie dieser
zirkusfamilie
friedhof selber fühlt sich langsam etwas
müde zeit dass die junge generation das
ruder übernimmt
ich würde das nicht so
ausgestattet
dass sie durchsichtig glaube ist die
grünen
[Musik]
also
das gemacht
[Musik]
ja